La volta al món a peu, dia 261.
Bueno, aquest és el nou barret que tinc, que m'he comprat.
Es pot posar així o es pot posar al revés, perquè no es vegi la marca.
Probablement me'n poso al revés, però bueno, perquè veieu que és de marca Patagònia.
A veure, no m'acaba tampoc d'enamorar.
El veig una mica, no sé, no molt de senderisme, però és veritat que protegeix molt.
I és així com tirat cap avall, llavors és millor pel vent.
Bé, el que em vaig comprar aquell de 3 euros era massa recte i el que venia una mica de vent es volava.
Bé, té també per aquí, per aguantar el vent.
I el pamir apretarà molt aquí a Tajikistan, apretar molt el sol, llavors, bé, crec que pot estar bé.
No sé, potser m'acaba agradant al final.
Què més? La bandera, no? La veieu per aquí?
A veure quan trigo em perdo-la.
D'acord, què més? Són les 10 i pico.
Són les 10 i pico, llargues.
I encara no he començat a caminar.
Per què? Perquè estic pensant, bueno, probablement vagi al metge.
Ahir vaig activar el protocol de l'assegurança i em van dir, mira noi, si vols anar al metge,
bueno, m'han demanat les dades, el que et passava i tal, dius, vés a aquest hospital,
el que passa és que no tenim conveni amb ells, llavors hauràs de pagar i després tornem els diners.
I bueno, m'han dit l'ubicació de l'hospital i puc anar.
I jo crec que hauria d'anar.
I jo crec que potser no estigui tan malament, que hauria d'anar perquè és que és probablement l'últim lloc
en molt de temps, en un mes, on poder trobar un metge bé que parli anglès, saps?
Perquè fora d'Auxambe ja no.
I si tinc algú que s'ha de mirar bé?
Doncs això.
Començaré a caminar després del metge?
Doncs depèn de què digui el metge, començaré a caminar avui o tornaré a l'hotel,
perquè ja he fet el xic-out, i tornaré a fer check-in, no ho sé.
En qualsevol cas, abans de tot,
he decidit, com està a prop de l'hotel,
venir a aquesta mesquita, que és la mesquita de...
No ho sé com es diu.
És la primera o la segona, no en tinc clar, mesquita més gran de Centràsia.
I és enorme.
És enorme.
Enorme.
Bueno, anem a fer una ullada.
Com els agrada el blau, eh?
Però aquesta blanca, aquesta té d'això blanca.
És molt grana.
Ui, m'estan dient.
M'he de vestir.
Mira, no puc anar així amb pantalons curts.
Vaja.
No, no era.
No era que havia de posar-me part de part amb els pantalons curts,
sinó que havia de deixar la motxilla.
L'he deixat allà.
Hi ha una cama de seguretat, espero que no passi res.
No hauria de passar res.
Aquesta mesquita té una particularitat,
que és que les dones de Tajikistan no poden entrar.
Només poden entrar homes de Tajikistan,
homes estrangers, com jo,
i també dones estrangeres.
Però dones de Tajikistan, no.
No sé.
No ho entenc molt bé però bueno.
Ok.
No.
Doncs no es podia visitar la part més gran i on hi ha les lampes i tot això de la mesquita, la part més gran no es podia visitar.
Doncs vaja, bé, doncs res, doncs ja ho hem vist. Una mesquita gran però tampoc té molt més.
Bueno, doncs he vingut a l'hospital. Ja veuràs, ja veuràs quin percalç serà això perquè m'atenguin. Ja veuràs com m'empenediré. Ja ho veuràs tu.
Surrealista. L'experiència mèdica més surrealista de la meva vida no ha estat ni 10 minuts.
Bueno, potser 10, però 5 d'ells han sigut xerrar. Xerrar de la meva volta al món i tal.
La resta, bé, en fi.
Entro a l'edifici.
Dic, hello, English? I apareix un home amb una bata de color blau. Ismail. Aquest senyor d'aquí. Un grec.
I llavors em comença a parlar en anglès. Li començo a explicar el que em passa, tal.
Però el tio sense entrar-me ni a un despatx d'aquests de metges ni res.
I bueno, doncs començo a explicar els símptomes, tal. Em diu, ah, no et preocupis.
Bueno, t'hauràs de prendre unes medicines.
Ara anem a la farmàcia i ho comprem.
I jo el compro. No ho entenc. No ho entenc, ja.
Al meu país, primer t'ha de veure un metge i després et recepta unes medicines.
I doncs et diu la freqüència que te les depèn. T'ho apunten un paper, no?
Em diu, no, però qui t'aixequi tant ho fem diferent.
Anem a la farmàcia que està aquí just al costat i, bueno, compro una medicina.
I m'ha dit, això, ho has d'aprendre, doncs, tres cops al dia, els primers dos dies.
I després, doncs, només dos. I quan estiguis bé ja pots deixar d'aprendre.
I has de beure molts líquids.
I bueno, doncs ja està. I em porta a la...
Diu, bueno, ara hem d'anar a veure el líder del grup d'emergències.
És un tio que no parla l'anglès.
I bueno, res, doncs mira, l'enric, tal. M'he pres unes pastilles, ja està, adeu.
I doncs després he estat parlant amb l'Ismael.
I ja està. Després ha aparegut gent amb bata blanca que tenia més pinta de metge.
Pinta, saps? No, què sé, a vegades la pinta és la pinta.
I li pregunto, ah, però...
Però normalment, clar, s'ha de veure un metge.
Diu, no, bueno, jo soc tècnic d'ambulàncies. M'ha dit...
M'ha semblat que m'ha dit això.
I jo...
Ah, vale.
Ok.
I els metges han passat i m'han escoltat, tan tranquil.
Vull dir, no, no ha semblat com si fos res estrany.
I no ha fet cap paper. Evidentment.
Ni cap factura.
Però no m'han cobrat res. Només m'han cobrat la medicina aquesta que m'ha costat dos euros i mig.
Tu diràs, no, això no cal ni que ho passi pel seguro, és igual, saps?
Eh, no sé.
No sé, no sé, no sé.
I em diu tal, m'ha donat el WhatsApp, ens hem fet la foto, ja me l'enviaràs, tal...
No sé, molt surrealista, no?
A veure, si estigués greu jo...
M'hauria dit, no, no, sisplau.
Deixem, sentar-me amb un metge i dir-li...
I explicar-li tot.
Bé, que tampoc tinc això, que tampoc és tal...
Bé...
Doncs res, no sé què dir, no sé què dir.
Ara hauré d'escriure als dies de l'assegurança
i dir-los, mira, ha passat això.
No m'han cobrat res ni m'han fet cap paper.
Vull dir que ja podeu tancar l'expedient.
Bé, són les dotze i mitja.
Potser podria menjar alguna cosa i després començar a caminar.
No seria mala idea.
Doncs, mentre passo el carrer us explico que acabo de fer el meu últim àpat occidental
en molt de temps.
Home, Enric, això no es va per la panxa.
El local estava en condicions higièniques perfectes.
Per tant, això és el que compta per mi.
Què més?
M'he parlat amb l'assocurs escrivà, que s'ha quedat bastant...
M'ha dit, m'ha dit...
Bé, clar, això en aquests països ja se sap, saps?
Val, i ara toca anar a Correus.
Que al principi és per aquí dintre, cosa que no acabo d'entendre.
Jo crec que no, eh?
A Correus sí, perquè...
Això no tinc per què fer-ho, eh?
Però hi ha gent que s'ha donat d'alta aquest agost
i no li vaig enviar la postal d'Uzbekistan,
perquè la vaig enviar a principi d'agost.
Llavors, home, em sap greu que hagin pagat aquest mes, no?
I no hagin rebut la postal, perquè no els he enviat.
Llavors, bueno, envio la de Tadjikistan.
Tinc els meus dubtes de que arribin, les de Tadjikistan, eh?
Però bueno, tu, aquesta gent tindrà una postal molt exclusiva,
que és la de Tadjikistan, eh?
No n'he pogut comprar més, n'he comprat unes quinze,
per aquestes persones que s'han donat d'alta.
Si la rebeu, m'aviseu, eh?
Que la de Tadjikistan, crec que és una postal molt preuada,
també l'envio a un dels meus pares,
perquè tinguin la col·lecció completa.
Tres soms m'ha costat que assageï.
Que barat!
30 cèntims, postal internacional.
Si ho arribo a saber, les envio totes des d'aquí, del món mundial.
El país més barat, però amb molta diferència, eh?
Compara amb això, amb Georgia,
que valien dos euros amb 60, crec que, de postal.
Aquí, 30 cèntims!
I només n'he enviat quinze, tu. Bueno, en fi.
Vale, ja està.
Estic al lloc on ahir vaig acabar la ruta.
Bastant diferent que ahir.
Són les dues del migdia.
38 graus, bona hora per començar a caminar, tu.
Fresqueta.
La màxima del dia d'avui.
Ja es veu Pols, que ahir per la nit no es veia.
Doncs res, a veure fins on arribo.
Si faig 20 quilòmetres ja serà molt,
perquè suposo que hauré d'anar parant.
Let's go.
A algú no fa molta ràbia que digui let's go?
És que m'agrada dir let's go.
També puc dir som-hi, no? Vinga, som-hi.
Bé, doncs, m'he parat aquí ara després de 10 quilòmetres.
he gravat un altre vídeo ara però
el noi que m'ha donat
aquesta aigua, molt simpàtic, no vol sortir el vídeo
llavors doncs torno a gravar
i re tu, doncs molt amable
la gent aquí, vaig prenent també benzineres
a comprar aigua
i bé, doncs
perquè m'han dit que m'he hidratat molt
però a més tinc set
he de dir que fa moltíssima calor però
ho porto millor que l'altre dia, suposo que clar
l'altre dia estava cansat, feia 6 dies que no anava a un hotel
i ara doncs estic més descansat
fa 3 dies que no camino
i tal, bueno, dos
llavors millor, millor, a més va caient la tarda
hi ha alguns arbres, m'han donat
ombra
i em sembla que la medicina està fent efecte
perquè no estic anant
al lavabo, no he anat ni una vegada
espero que després no faci
efecte rebote i em surti tot a cop
però bé, bé, bé, doncs res
descanso una estona més i segueixo
10 quilòmetres, força bé
tinc un equip de dos representants que em porten les col·laboracions
i
ostres, soc un
per rentar el negoci en els preus
i ara faré una cosa que no hauria de fer, que és promocionar
aquesta tenda gratis
però bé, suposo que aquí no vindrà ningú
me n'aniré i tio, a veure si promocionaràs el nostre negoci
doncs si, si, mira, si teniu algun problema
i passeu per Tadjikistan
veniu a aquest negoci d'aquí
no sabria dir-vos tampoc on soc
estic a les afores de l'Uxambe
i bueno, us donaran aigua
i si veniu de part meva, doncs
digueu-s'hi que veniu del...
del noi boig que camina
ja us entendran
no he caminat ni...
ni dos quilòmetres des de l'altre lloc
no has dit res?
és per mi?
és de tieta
Rahmat
Hitoy
moltes gràcies
tu ets l'enhorabona
ni dos quilòmetres he caminat des de l'altre lloc
i aquest senyor m'ha donat aigua
i un gelat tu
havia vist una part de la gelat i dic, no agafis tant de gelat...
perquè és massa sucre, tot i que si te'l regalen, què has de fer?
Tanta aigua no la necessito, però bé, la carregaré, sí, ja està, ja la tinc.
Les 5 i 37, estic a Bagh, Bagh, Bagh, Baghdad.
És que sona molt a Baghdad, no?
Bueno, és un poble que està exercent a Dushanbe.
Hi ha de tot, tu, edificis alts, KFC,
i crec que és l'últim poble allà gran en bastants dies, sí.
Bueno, molt bé, porto bé el dia, estic bé, encara queda hora i mitja,
a veure si podem arribar als 20, jo crec que sí.
Anem bé, anem bé, la gent molt simpàtica, tothom saluda.
Bon humor i bon temps.
Anem bé, a veure si podem arribar als 20, jo crec que sí.
Anem bé, anem bé, la gent molt simpàtica, tothom saluda.
Bon humor i bon temps.
Són les 7, he estat enrere ja aquesta última petit població i toca acampar.
Aquí hi ha uns camps que, bueno, no tenen cap edificació al voltant,
per tant hauria d'estar bé.
El que sí que veig algun cotxe per allà, que probablement no passi res, però,
bé, no s'ha de més esquivar-los.
a esquivar-los. Llavors, bé, crec que ara amb breus em posaré aquí a la dreta i començaré a buscar.
Aquest sembla un bon lloc per entrar. Hi ha un camp que ja està cegat.
Anem a entrar cap aquí.
Bueno, bueno, bueno.
Molt bé. Ui, hi ha un gos allà. Bé, no passa res. Els gossos d'aquí, en aquest país, no són problema.
Bueno, doncs camino una mica més a veure què trobo. Salto d'un camp a un altre, aquest em fa millor espina. Ara, no matar-me.
Ui, és molt empinat això. A veure, aquests arbres espero que estiguin ben ferms.
Ui, ja està.
Vale, doncs a veure cap allà. Ui, aquí sembla perfecte.
És una plantació d'arbres fruiters, pel que sembla, pomers o alguna cosa així.
Llavors, els arbres empinat.
Es protegeixen de la vista i, com veieu, l'herba està molt baixa.
Allà hi ha com una espècie de camí, però, bé, dubto que hi vagi molta gent.
Jo crec que em poso per aquí, eh? Uf, estic cansat.
Resum, avui 21 quilòmetres, dos refrescos, he parlat amb dues persones i cap cafè.
Els últims dies que no us he dit el que m'he gastat, doncs en total m'he gastat 190 euros,
que és bastant. El barret em va costar 35, crec, i la nit d'hotel cada nit 34, amb esmorzar inclòs,
però era l'habitació privada més barata de tot Dushanbe, o sigui, d'aquí cap amunt.
M'ha sorprès, m'ha sorprès el preu. Sí, sí. I tampoc hi ha una granitació, eh?
Però, bueno, tenia tassa, tenia dutxa i tenia aire acondicionat, que és el que compta. I with it.
Molt bé.
Avui, un dia de transició, però, tenint en compte que jo m'espantava una mica per la calor, doncs, bueno,
l'he pogut superar, només 21 quilòmetres, però està bé.
Demà més, i dir-vos una cosa, que és que hi ha molta gent que em pregunta, jo pensava que ho havia dit,
però potser no ho havia dit, que és que al final dels vídeos no surt el logo de la Generalitat,
perquè ja es va acabar la beca, la beca a propulsió, que és els diners que em van donar per fer aquests vídeos,
es van acabar el 31 de juliol, i jo, doncs...
estic fent els vídeos, però ara ja no estan patrocinats, entre cometes, per la Generalitat, becats,
llavors, doncs, per això fico això diferent al final, però, tot i igual, és que pensava que ho havia dit,
serà tot igual, vídeos diaris, bueno, quan pugui, lo de sempre, freqüència diària, gairebé diària,
en català, independentment de si està la Generalitat o si està una altra.
D'acord, senyors, fins demà, bona nit.
Fins demà.